Hello everybody, Dr. Kevin Cutters. This is episode 7 of my journey in my cancer diagnosis.
Hey, again, this is very personal so this is not necessarily what you would want to do.
This use with this episode is not as using the right therapy and we use the right therapy at all of our patients.
That's really what got me in to helping people with cancer was my
love for what Royal Rife did in what I studied about him and how he helped people with his dealing with light frequency and using a testletube with light frequency that helped it heal people.
That's what intrigued me and intrigued me when I studied his work what I was in car practice school back in the 1980s.
And I always thought that I always wanted to have a right machine but I thought well it was only really for use of dealing with cancer patients and of course I wasn't a cancer doctor so but I had studied his work and was always intrigued by it and at that time picked out a right machine that I wanted to buy and had the brochure up it was a light beam generator that I was going to purchase.
Then that's what I thought was the best one out there at that time and a beam ray so when I had a patient come to me and told me she needed help with her cancer and she was going to refuse chemo and radiation on the grounds of her nursing a good friend through a chemo and that friend had died and that patient did not want to go through that same journey that that friend did.
And she said I would rather die and then do that so she wanted my help and that was my moment when I first bought my first right machine back in the late 90s and that was that started really my journey with helping other patients with cancer.
So I bought a light beam generator and then soon after that a beam ray and started to help her with that she used that in my office she'd come into my office every day she was retired and she lived in other 13 15 years I believe she died of a heart attack she was in her 80s and were late 70s and so that was that was her story.
It was just a wonderful story and said God sent me other kids or patients we always use the knife with them. I'm not going to go into royal rife's story of this video I have a whole bunch of videos on my website about rife therapy and what he did he was called a quack he was basically run out of town and he back went all the other kids or clinics that were not using chemo there.
Therapy and pharmaceuticals were all shut down royal rife and his little clinic was shut down at the same time and all his information was basically confiscated and you could read a bunch of information on that this is the royal rife story that is a video it's a wonderful video there's stuberos videos documentaries on him numerous books that were written about him too and what his work was.
And how he did help people truth about cancer has a series on rife frequency therapy and with rife frequency it is all about frequency and just understanding quantum physics and frequencies everything done to a smallest particle simply energy that's vibrating at a frequency and if you can hit cancer in its own frequency all sorts of good things can happen for the patient who has cancer so rife believe that you would actually cause cell lysis.
Of the cancer cell if you hit it with its own frequency because he could observe that in a petri dish so he thought that that happened in the living person's body as well now I don't believe that that is actually what happens with rife therapy it hasn't been proven that that happens there's lots of other good things that happen when you hit a cancer in its own frequency you cause that cell the vibrate which could cause an immune response.
After that cell you could help detoxify the waist layer around the cancer you certainly are alkalizing the cancer when you hit it with its own frequency you are causing an immune stimulation to the cancer there's dubious theories I think all of them have validity on why rife actually works with cancer patients now I will say it is not a magic one it is not a cure for cancer.
I don't believe that anything we do is cured cancer I don't think I'm cured by cancer doing all the therapies that I'm doing I'm just helping my body be able to have victory over this that's what my goal is and if I can give myself extra months and years that's really what my purpose is in all these therapies so that's what our desire is we're not looking to cure anybody per se only god could do that we're looking to stimulate the body so that the body could do its work.
And if the body could cure us well that's god's choice in that so we have to use the right frequencies that's the key that was my real quest with my diagnosis because I have such a rare type of cancer that it is a quote unquote colon cancer it is metastatic extra memory
panchist disease so getting the right frequencies was a little bit tricky on my part until I had the right diagnosis that I could run the right frequencies at least the ones that we believed the where the right least when I believe no are the right frequencies and I'm continue to do scary to make sure I could tweak that and figure out new frequencies for my type of cancer and then you have to use a machine so we currently use a true rife machine with most of our patients
and we have another radio frequency machine that we use in our office as well that's the GB 4000 that we use in our office as well so those are some of the machines that we use the benefit of the trifles that we could use all night long and we use the hammer tube that's what this one is I'm
experimenting with this crystallized hammer tube which is a relatively new hammer tube which can help divide the frequencies up as they go through the crystals so I'm going to have some of the advantages it's impossible to measure whether it's better than this one or not but I'm we'll see I'm happy with it so far we have some patients using that as well but that's rife therapy I honestly wholeheartedly believe
that I don't think anybody should go through their battle with cancer without using rife therapy we have seen literal miracles with it I would always be cautious to say that it is not a magic one it doesn't cure people of cancer but we've had people that were given two weeks to live by mail live it extra five years
live an extra four years it's just been miraculous we had one guy that was given two weeks to live from mail that he came in about four days after that that diagnosis from mail and he lived an extra three and a half years and when he died his son was so adamant that he didn't have kids or that he ordered an autopsy and he died of cirrhosis the liver caused by the chemotherapy that he had prior to him cubby to us he had to pay
for a cancer and his son was so thankful he actually read the autopsy at his at the autopsy report at his father's funeral so it is the interesting thing about that one case that guy just he just basically he took
some supplements that I gave him but he basically just refused to change his diet to any other detox therapies because he just had
no interest in doing any of that that he really had no major belief that the rife was going to do anything for him but he did it and we saw some great results with him
so they can have really good results and we've seen good results with with people say that they had good results with their pets and such too and you know
that there's no placebo effect with them so I'm convinced of the efficacy of the rife therapy I am not a physicist
so I'm not going to be able to explain to you why it works I just know that I have seen some terrific things with it
I would never try to treat my cancer without using the rife machine having that be a piece of the protocol that is probably
even though this is an episode seven this is probably my major therapy that I do hands down even above diet and any of the other nutritional things
this is the major piece so more information of this is on our website too if you want to look at it
all by patients that are watching this the reason why I put this on episode seven is really because this journey is for my patients and every single one of my patients is already doing the rife
so it's a no-brainer for them all right thank you very much we'll talk to you next time